okay let's move over to to joe biden he
was at fema yesterday discussing some
covid stuff
and you know he's mostly when he does
these things he usually reads off notes
and that's just fine by the way i've got
a couple notes here not much i scribble
down a few things
and i'm mostly just talking off the top
of my head i'm not comparing myself to
the president of the united states but
i'm not
sitting here saying that i have to have
every single thing memorized and the
rest of it
but biden you know when he gives
speeches obviously it's mostly off
prompter and that's one of the weird
things about his mumbles and fumbles
because
reading a prompter is is just reading
and i've mentioned this before sometimes
when you read a teleprompter
so right now the way i'm looking at you
guys i actually do have a prompter in
front of me all it says is
biden mumbles fina fema it's just it's
the
top line of what i'm doing for you guys
right now but occasionally you're going
to fumble over some words you could lose
some of it
it happens to him all the time anyway
he's giving this talk at fema yesterday
and he's got the notes right in front of
him and just
just listen to this and look at the way
everybody's looking at him and you tell
me it's something
wrong here but uh there's
you know there to be you know beginning
uh
this effort for 2021 is
i think we've learned a few lessons from
last year as well
there's help as we they're you know
being there to help
clear roads rebuild main streets
and so that the families can get back to
their lives
that's what fema does every single day
what like what he's got the notes right
in front of him he doesn't know what
he's saying he's mumbling and fumbling
and bumbling
those people are obviously looking at
him like something
ain't right here everyone knows
something ain't
right and the more that they don't cover
this they're not gonna cover that on cnn
and by the way
i'm not saying that they have to lead
with that story and have doctors on
every two seconds like when
donald trump remember donald trump drank
a glass of water with two hands and then
he walked slowly
down a ramp and then they said he had
neurological disorders in the rest of it
i'm not saying
they have to go all in on that except
this is just another one of those things
where the more they don't cover it what
everyone can see is
anyone watching this right now any
single person
that just saw what i just showed you do
you not think something is wrong there
something is obviously wrong by the way
some of it could just be age he's
getting up there
he's tired i can't imagine the amount of
hours they've got him doing things and
the amount of information he has to have
and all
of that stuff not that i think he's in
charge of any of this stuff but when
he's sitting there with notes in front
of him and he can't pull together a
basic
sentence we know damn well
if this was a republican and especially
trump
they would they would actually be
calling for impeachment already they'd
be calling for people to be arrested
that are around him like is there any
doubt that that is true
and and just one more thing on this i
don't mean this to be a dick
i really don't look it's my cards are on
the table here do i like
biden no do i think the democrats are
evil yes
do i think that a whole bunch of
horrific ideas are being imported
in the name of diversity and tolerance
that this guy is ushering in yes
all of those things are true but i would
prefer that the guy who is supposedly
flying the plane right now if the united
states is the plane
i would hope that this guy was mentally
competent and it's fairly
obvious that he isn't so we should be
allowed to talk about it
but unfortunately you ain't gonna see
that on cnn or msnbc so
good luck with all of that